[Music]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen welcome we're
looking forward to informative and fun
discussion bill and I will look at the
future the road ahead or what will be
depending on what book title you like we
have agreed to focus on the bigger
picture
further out longer range rather than
shorter range stay away from brand name
discussions and issues try to see how it
might affect our way of living our
lifestyle our society bill will begin
will go for 10 to 15 minutes maybe
twelve and a half plus or minus two and
a half and I will do the same then maybe
we'll fight with each other for five
minutes and turn it over for Q&A live
Q&A with microphones to the floor so let
us we get bill well it's a very very
exciting time in terms of giving people
better tools of communication these
actually calling them tools of
communication may not give the the full
import of what a variety of things
people will be able to do with PCs
connected up to the Internet I created a
new term which is that people either
live a web lifestyle or they don't live
a web lifestyle now what I mean by that
is that somebody who several times a day
goes to the web several times a day
checks electronic mail sends electronic
mail and for any new topic or anything
they want to do they take it as a given
that they're gonna turn to the Internet
to be informed and collaborate that's
somebody living a web lifestyle and very
few people are doing that today if you
want to find large groups that meet that
test you have to go to universities
particularly some university campuses
in the united states where the only way
you sign up for courses is to get on the
web the way you arrange things with your
friends the way you order pizzas is is
through the web and my view is that as
those young people move into the economy
and more and more people have that kind
of experience that this that those
consumers will demand companies to to
use the web in a very very creative way
whether it's for paying bills or taxes
or selling products are simply just
informing them I think we can already
see that the efficiencies to be gained
through the new medium are pretty
incredible one distinction you can make
is that some people will live a web
lifestyle in their office well before
they do it as part of their home life
there's a quite a divergence in terms of
the bandwidth that will be available to
businesses in the near term and in the
office versus in the home if we take
though a 10-year period I think the
Internet has been greatly underestimated
in the next two or three years I think
it's almost been overestimated some of
the articles that go on and on about how
everybody's going to be shopping they're
banking there or buying their cars there
it's just not realistic it it it takes
time for this to happen some of the key
breakthroughs have not been made yet
flat-panel screens with wonderful
resolution are not yet available now
there are lots of companies pursuing
quite a variety of techniques including
straightforward refinement of approaches
that we use today as well as
revolutionary approaches that I feel
certain will deliver that sometime in
the next five to ten years
there are many software companies
working on the very tough problems of
letting you interface with a computer in
some way other than using a keyboard and
a pointing device the Microsoft research
group is very oft to me
take that speech recognition speech
synthesis visual recognition will be
primary ways of working with a a
computer and the cost of the hardware to
do these things is very straightforward
you need a pretty good microphone and a
semi-decent
camera but the extra cost of those built
into any type of device will be you know
on the order of a hundred dollars or
well less as the volume goes up there
and so when we talk about the PC and
where the PC is going it's important to
keep in mind the rapid innovation
particularly the rapid innovation
innovation in the user interface a year
ago people were talking about that the
internet and the PC didn't really go
together well today through our efforts
and efforts of many other companies
those things go together very very well
in fact if you buy a new PC it the
Internet is a few clicks away you just
merely pick the service provider that
you want and how you want to be built
for that and you're up and running even
the software that lets you do Internet
telephony internet meetings all of those
things are coming built into the
computer so you don't have to go out and
take a lot of trouble to set those up
right now people are worried about the
complexity of the PC and this is a very
legitimate worry whether it comes in
terms of cost of ownership or the
difficulty of updating software or the
confusion people have once again I I
have a very optimistic viewpoint here
partly through insight knowledge of
things that are being done and and
partly just a the view of how rapidly
software can improve people are going to
be surprised probably in the next year
but certainly over the next several
years on how that PC interface can can
be improved how we can take things and
hide them from the user and be doing
more for the users so that underneath
there's a lot going on but when you sit
down to use
it's it's very very straightforward you
just think of the documents you want to
use you think of the topics you're
interested in and that kind of
experience can be delivered against the
PC it's a very competitive business it's
a business where no product that's out
today will be popular in three or four
years so it's simply a question of the
companies who make products are they
going to replace their own product or
are they going to let somebody else come
in and do that I thought the picture
that Annie painted today was a very
important picture another speech of his
that I think was was quite good was one
that he gave at Comdex where he looked
10 years out at what kind of chips Intel
would be making and you know when he
talked about gigahertz clock speeds and
the instruction speeds mean a hundred
times what they are today it's very
clear that we need to do more than just
run a spreadsheet or a word processor to
take good advantage of that and that
that's where supply and demand come
together in the software that learns
about the user and becomes a reasonable
assistant in helping you in every way in
this this information economy comes
across a final concept is one that I
talked about my book and that's friction
free capitalism the these tools are
going to take capitalism which has
always had the the frictional problem of
buyers and sellers locating each other
it's going to take that in reduce the
frictional costs very very dramatically
and so even markets in consulting which
are very poorly mediated today it's hard
to find the best consultant when you
find a consultant you don't know that
you didn't like look at all the people
who are willing to do that work it's
just that a friend mention it to you
markets like that the availability of
people their references their price all
will be there in your ability to
collaborate with them at a distance will
be very dramatic so it's a good thing
capitalism work
because this tool will be used to bring
it to new new levels of effectiveness on
a global basis and and really make the
world a far smaller place okay well
let's see I believe we're headed to
about half a billion to 1 billion
interconnected computers by the year
2007 Andy thinks my half a billion
estimate is low now what will all these
computers the interconnected computers
and the people behind them be doing I
have a simple model I like to think of
it's called the information marketplace
and it says that all these computers and
their people will be doing three things
one of three things or more of them
they'll be buying selling or freely
exchanging information and information
work now to me the latter is very
important because when we think of
information we think usually of text
pictures video sounds what I like to
call information as a noun but there is
this other thing which is information
work massaging information altering it
which is information as a verb it's done
by computer programs like Bill's
Microsoft Word and others and it's done
by people like accountants and tax
clerks and so on it turns out that the
fraction of the industrial economy that
consists of office workers is huge it's
about half of the economy so I think a
lot of this new medium this new world
the networked society will really have
information work flowing over it as well
as of course information as a noun which
is the one we talked about and the
content and so forth but this huge
amount which is nine trillion dollars of
information work gives us an idea of how
big things could be on the financial
side but there will be also free
exchanges and things that will be not
measured in dollars one of the things I
in what will be is the possibility of a
virtual Peace Corps a gigantic Clearing
House were the providers of help and
those who wish to receive help find
their place over the World Wide Web
it's gonna be a big site or a big server
but with a lot of compartments for
different kinds of activities there is a
lot of this in the world there are a lot
of people who need help a lot of people
who can provide it and why not provide a
clearinghouse where these two could be
matched and the help doesn't have to go
always from the wealthy to the not
wealthy I could envision a Sri Lankan
doctor providing medical help through
the networked society to a homeless
person in San Francisco where the hair
would be the care would be affordable
now I think the movement that we're
seeing will be fully integrated into our
lives it would be pretty much like air
water breathing it will not be a cyber
space out there that we go visit it'll
be in everything we do I agree with Bill
I think speech will be the dominant
interface because the technology is here
and because we're born with mouths and
ears rather than with keyboard and mouse
sockets in terms of what are the big
forces what can we reduce all these
thousands of things we've been talking
about here - a few fundamental forces I
believe we can I believe the first force
is what I like to call electronic
bulldozers the ability of our computers
to offload human work from the human
brain I'm not talking about creativity
or complex things but simple work that
we do repetitive work processing and
x-ray annotating it etc offloading human
work now we think that we're doing this
and we are to some extent but if you
look at what we do with a world wide web
and with electronic mail we are using a
hundred percent our eyes and our brains
in pre-industrial terms it's as if we
had shovels
then somebody handed us a shovel that
said hi-tech shovel and we kept tumbling
it it's time to stop doing things with
our brains entirely clerical simple
things throw the high-tech shovels away
and automate a lot of the activities
among the the machines to relieve us of
work I know that computers are good for
a lot of other things beyond increasing
our productivity but now socio-economic
movement worth its salt has lasted if it
didn't also help human productivity and
I think this one will and it might take
us even as high up the productivity
curve as the industrial movement did it
maybe that will see a 300% increase in
office productivity during the 21st
century the second force is the force of
electronic proximity as I like to call
it that is the very exciting part of the
web and of these other technologies that
bring brings people closer together now
it's amazing how big this force is when
we were in the villages there were maybe
we could reach 200 people a hundred
people in our lifetime by walking when
the cart came that number increased by a
factor of a thousand we could now reach
potentially two hundred thousand people
maybe we wouldn't reach all of them but
we could reach them by driving now the
amazing thing to me is that the
Information Age increases this ability
by yet another factor of a thousand and
we can reach 200 300 million people we
won't reach them but we can it's it's a
very strange notion it brings all of us
closer together and this world will have
it's good things like communities of
seniors and handicapped people and all
the network groups that will be helping
each other commercially and otherwise
but it'll also have info crime and info
predators and all the problems that come
with with proximity let me touch a
little bit on culture there is a great
fear that this increased proximity is
going to impose a universal culture in
the world or that some nation will take
its culture and try to impose it on
another I won't mention any names
let me suggest to you that this new
technology that we're all witnessing has
the very strange capability of
strengthening simultaneously ethnicity
and diversity let me explain
I'm a Greek and half of the Greeks are
outside Greece half of the Jews are
outside Israel and half for the
Palestinians I could go on even 20% of
the Canadians are outside Canada and as
the world becomes increasingly global
more people will be outside their
landmass that is their nation now if we
could use the networked society to keep
connected among us the Greeks outside
and inside then we might have the very
strange situation where 30 years from
now 50 years from now the Greek nation
isn't the landmass in the Mediterranean
but it's a network it's a frightening
notion the Greek nation Network actually
it's much closer much closer to the
notion of nation ethnos the Greek notion
which implied that you could be anywhere
and being in that national circle
fascinating thought on the site of
diversity let's just look at the
European Union the presence of a common
language like English has not
obliterated the national differences
it's a thin cultural veneer that permits
the people to communicate with each
other along with other conventions
taxation and so on but underneath are
the gigantic national indigenous
cultures of Europe Greeks are Greeks
Italians are Italians and so on I expect
exactly the same thing to happen in this
new medium no universal culture but a
thin veneer a thin veneer of shared
culture that's gonna bind us and level
some of our differences help us
understand each other but still
strengthened ethnicity
well i believe in vir we disagree with
bill that left to its own devices the
movement will increase the gap between
rich and poor people and between rich
and poor nations the reason to my
thinking is that information helps the
rich because it helps with the material
goods that the rich had have in them and
the services that they offer so it helps
them do them more efficiently and they
get better and richer the poor cannot
afford these technologies or to learn
about them so they stay behind and the
gap will increase mind you I'm saying
left to its own devices that means we
should help we should help with a
variety of measures but if we don't I
believe the gap will increase the next
point is that if we have a billion
computers which sounds reasonable in 10
to 15 years and on each of them there's
between a thousand and a million pieces
of information
the grand total if I do my arithmetic
right is between a trillion and a
quadrillion pieces of information and
what is useful to this person is not
useful to me or what useful to me is not
useful to that person so there's a huge
amount of info chunk floating around and
I think that is going to make necessary
middlemen brokers people and to some
extent computers that will help match
the various interest it's as if in a
marketplace people came from both sides
huge numbers of people there would be a
tremendous chaos if there wasn't a way
to sort things out I think this is
another area where we might disagree
bill agents computer agents are
overrated and overhyped at this stage of
their history anyway and because they
can't have human intelligence or
anywhere near it so they can't really
help much I think I've talked too much
I'd like to say something about human
relations and how they fare through this
medium but I'll save this for a later on
for the time being let me just conclude
by saying that I think we are into this
third major socio-economic movement and
we need not fear it anymore unless
than we feared the automobile
electricity chemicals steam engines I
think we ought to embrace it we are
after all the same ancient humans we've
always been with the same ancient goals
and aspirations all that's changing is a
new set of tools thank you I think it's
between you and me for five minutes well
let me talk about rich rich and poor a
little bit and see where the core of the
disagreement is I disagree pretty
strongly about rich nation versus poor
nation I today if you wanted to know
what somebody's yearly income was and
you could only ask them one question
about themselves the question you would
ask is what country do you live in that
is the dominant factor for vast
differences in income I claim that with
this network the question you will ask
ten years from now is what is your
education level and that you'll have a
much better predictor asking about
education level then you will about
their geography now what what do I mean
concretely I mean that the high paying
jobs today are service related jobs
manufacturing jobs were allowed to move
around the world to the person who was
willing to bid for them at the best
price by low-cost transportation this
network now allows that same geographic
dispersion of the high paying jobs you
can design things you can translate
things you can you can do all those nice
service-oriented things you can even you
know be a lawyer in laws of another
country if people are willing to pay you
enough and you can deliver that in a
nice videoconference way and collaborate
and so countries that don't have good
educational structures
we'll have a problem with this but the
human resources of non developing
countries of India and China you know
they're there basically is a pretty
reasonable educational system there and
the motivation to become well educated
in these areas will be so dramatic that
I think will actually see a leveling and
it won't take that long before we'll see
this lovely ok I fully agree I fully
agree about the potential and I fully
agree even that we can use the
technology to help in various parts of
the world with health with learning with
matching labor to other parts of the
world I fully agree with all that my
problem is that left to its own devices
I just did a calculation and checked it
in the u.s. we spend 10% of our economy
on computer hardware computer software
and the computer the salaries of the
people who write computer programs
so you could say computing is about 10%
of our GNP Germany and Japan are pretty
close I checked that number in
Bangladesh and we had a lot of trouble
getting the numbers we had to go all the
way up the Bangladeshi embassy finally
we estimated it it was less than 1/10 of
1% today
now that's to be expected but bill where
will the poor nations and the poor
people within any nation find the money
to buy the hardware to buy the software
to get educated about the indigenous
things that computers need to do so that
they can give of their education and
services well I guess it shows my faith
in capitalism there will be middlemen
that will emerge who will invest in the
education in equipping with hardware
people in Bangladesh in order that they
can take a 10% fee on the wonderful
service work that those people will do
the power of capitalism to mediate that
I think is pretty incredible now I have
to admit governments have a big role
here in terms of putting in the
communications infrastructure
in terms of the large cities in these
countries and universities there I think
we're probably okay on that going out
beyond that I'm partly very optimistic
about satellite systems including the
Teledesic one or others like that coming
along and providing very high-speed
bandwidth to every part of the globe and
I'm quite optimistic about even as pcs
become more powerful and simpler that
the average price will go down so the
act of mediation required here I don't
think is is very difficult the one the
only one question mark on my thing is is
the education systems will they rise to
that challenge
another factor I think comes in to this
is rich countries a little bit get lazy
and the poor countries try harder given
a chance they try harder and you get
this leveling effect so our difference
seems to be that you believe that
through capitalism middlemen will help
and I seem to think that we need to help
a little more through perhaps our
governments setting up some libraries
some places where people can use and
learn about the machines and through
individual and corporate donations of
help and money and hard no that's not
that's not the point of disagreement no
I I think it's important that not be
disappointed
I am the a absolutely a big believer
that anything we can do to make this
come true
sooner is great my claim is that year by
year the gap gets less but I think it's
absolutely worth having governments and
philanthropist accelerate that the
disagreement is do they go apart and
then come together I claim they go
together and it's it's in our power to
make that sooner than later
for example in the same way that books
have been available to people to give
them a chance to read and learn I think
that in those libraries we should have
pcs connected to the internet anybody
should be able to go in and use those
and you know I I want to make sure that
I happen sooner than later let's leave
that to be the last word and we spent
five minutes fighting not too hard but
maybe we can do some more fighting later
audience we have taken 30 precious
minutes of your life now we'd like to
hear from you please questions I know at
first were timid but after a while
you'll be competing for the microphone
so give it a try
if you raise your hand there are mics
around someone will bring you that
quadrant and another hand on this
quadrant
build my gut question how many hours in
your research do you find people are
able or willing to spend in front of a
screen on a daily basis and how will
that affect all the distribution that
you plan to put through the PC well you
know the average American household
somehow sits in front of a TV a hundred
hours a week now somebody who sits in
front of a TV zero hours a week
I find it mind-blowing I mean it's a
it's not a very high quality screen and
it's not interactive so people's ability
to sit in front of a video display seems
to be very high and the quality of these
screens will improve dramatically
you know I don't read The Wall Street
Journal or The Economist long things off
of the screen I still read them on paper
if I want to look for a specific article
or get get it a little bit faster than I
can otherwise then I'll go on to the
electronic but the I admit that the
screen the field of view and resolution
still has some drawbacks but that that
will go away eventually your whole desk
will be a screen your walls will be
screens and seriously come to my house
let me let me add a little bit here from
the history of this business which I've
been watching for the last 35 years and
living it at MIT we would get students
they would sit in front of the terminal
in fact the guy who invented the
spreadsheet who was a student of mine
Frankston he used to just work so long
that he would finally fall asleep with
his face on the terminal and we had to
lift him not because we were
compassionate but to free up the
terminal
but even Frankston and everybody else or
perhaps not frankly but the people who
exhibited this addictive behavior after
a while lower down and adapt and my
point is that we human beings have
thousands and thousands of years of
experience in adapting and my answer to
you sir is that we will adapt to
whatever it takes so we don't get too
tired too anxious and so forth more
questions
a couple of telegraphic questions Anna
mrs. Sharma sharif regarding the future
of the networked society and their or
the global information society and just
rethinking the way things happened
during this century regarding having
people who thought about having cities
having buildings having highways and at
the point in time they put the blueprint
of the society around them and putting
what you've just said both of you
together don't you think we need to put
at different levels government industry
professionals the blueprint of this
global information society one - what
about the tele desk project is it and
still in the Dreaming phase or there is
anything which is more than has been
what has been reported that we can you
can share with us well let's let me
start with the second part Teledesic s--
a very exciting company because their
their goal is to build a very high speed
internet in the sky and it's very
complementary to what's being done by
communications companies around the
world in terms of running fibre there
are parts of the world where you just
don't have the density even the rural
United States world Europe you just
don't have the density they ever run out
the fibers to give those people the
capacity and that's where the satellite
a low-earth orbiting satellite can come
in and give you extremely high capacity
in these areas and then transfer that if
if the destination is into a city
transfer it down to a ground station
where it goes through the optic fiber
network or vice versa and so Teledesic i
hope it's not a dream they're spending
serious amounts of my money and it's
it's a capitalistic venture where Craig
McCaw who was involved in the cellar
industries is the chairman of the
company
there are other people doing things that
are slightly different so it's it's not
the only company going after dating
connections in the sky and I'd say with
great confidence that one or multiple of
these schemes will fill in the gap that
the world has in this connectivity the
beauty of these satellite systems is
that the marginal cost of making it
available when you're over saying Molly
or you know some territory where you
might not get much revenue because the
marginal cost is zero you'll find a
price a clearing price to to offer
connectivity for every point on the
globe and so it's it's a fairly leveling
development that with luck will be in
place within five to six years okay I
don't want to comment on Teledesic
but all the comments that bill made
apply to all the other satellite schemes
namely the geosynchronous satellites
that cost a huge amount money three four
hundred million to put up into orbit but
of course they don't have the ability to
go around the world like the low Earth
orbit ones but all the other issues
reaching a lagoon in the Pacific and
absorbing bursts of traffic from the
cities are there
I think satellites are going to be a
very important part of this now on to
your blueprint question sir I don't know
exactly what you mean by this the
European Union has already been working
on this through the various papers and
government in the US has been studying
the national information infrastructure
but I think the bulk of this drive is
happening by the people who are finding
ways to use the internet and and
entrepreneurial companies are being born
and is this a little bit similar to what
happened before when manufacturing and
the factories were set up and then
electricity and the automobile came
there was a lot of activity by a lot of
people and if you wish capitalism which
which gave rise to these things so I'm
not sure how much centralization and
planning should take place here probably
will vary through the various cultures
of the world I would say which is the I
think the goal of writing a book about
this is to get a broad set of people
to think about what are the societal
issues you know to start thinking about
privacy and have versus have-nots and so
to the degree that that there needs to
be a broad agreement on a blueprint for
those tough issues I agree with you in
terms of a blueprint of what it all
looks like it's a lot better to just let
marketplace competition play this thing
out the opinions about what people are
gonna do on the Internet
you know just think two years ago what
they said would be happening now I mean
people were wrong you know ninety
percent wrong and I I think the way that
it the way that companies succeed and
fail you know this is is a wonderful
thing for high risk capitalism to jump
in or questions gentlemen given the fact
that our society today all our social
systems and value systems are centric
around employment and given your ideas
about massive increases of productivity
what's your vision of that relationship
between technology and employment I
struggled with this I struggled with
this thank you it's a very good question
and I even got spanked several times by
my colleague Bob Solow the Nobel Prize
winner in economics here is what I know
and it's very little
I believe productivity will increase we
have no assurances okay but we believe I
think generally there's a belief it will
increase after all things are done
inefficiently today and when we apply
all this horsepower to things that are
done haphazardly and efficiently you
expect some improvement so that will
increase the problem is that for
employment or unemployment to move we
have to understand what happens to
demand because unemployment happens when
those two are out of kilter the
productivity increases and demand
doesn't increase for example then people
are thrown off on this side and they
cannot do work now there will be
displacements even if those two track so
I'm convinced that there will be changes
in jobs people who are doing job a now
will not have
job in the future even if productivity
doesn't change but the key issue behind
your question what will happen to
employment unemployment hinges on what
will happen to demand and all my
economist friends say we don't know so
I'm afraid the answer is we don't know I
have a little bit more optimistic view
of this essentially demand in some areas
is finite when farmers got very very
productive and the price of food came
down people didn't eat ten times as much
I mean the ate meat so they were eating
more calories but there was a limit when
radial tires came into the car market
people didn't say wow these tires are
better will drive a lot more and so that
the amount of society's resources in the
car market shrink if you think of the
resources that go in today to printing
bills and mailing them out and answering
questions about those that that's huge
and this technology will greatly reduce
the number of people you need to handle
that but there are areas where I see
near infinite demand take education you
know why not if there's productivity
here why not have five children in a
classroom take medicine if there's all
this productivity why not have much
better personalized health care take
leisure time activities with all this
productivity we should have more options
there will have more wealth to spend
there eventually you'll you'll even
shorten the workweek you know people
will choose to to take more time off
maybe Americans will take longer
vacations I think that would be nice
that's not in the cards nothing your
turn but if you're talking about a
situation of such where all this
productivity plays out twenty years from
now I believe it's very very much what
will happen in principle elect at
leisure is available to us the thing
that's scary is that the Industrial
Revolution made it possible for us with
this multifold increase in productivity
to basically live in an essential way
the way we live before the Industrial
Revolution by working much less but our
working hours kept up and even in
so there's something inside us that
keeps us working hard but I agree with
your elective leisure is an option and
maybe in the long future it may be a way
in which we will go let's get some more
questions yes follow up on governance
point that we are discussing the impact
of information sharing on the way the
societies will be run NBC ms CNN berlin
wall penetration of information to the
society at large what do you think it
will do to the role of the governments
governments and governance at large I
think there's some exciting
opportunities with government I think
citizens will be more educated on the
issues they'll have a chance not just to
read the headlines but to dive in you
know if the headline says budget cut by
20 billion then go in and see well what
was the budget you know how is the money
spent how's that changed over time
there's various debates about how far we
should go with direct democracy but no
longer will the argument against direct
democracy be that it's just too
expensive to go out and consult all the
people will have a mechanism that makes
that a possibility and the economists
pointed out that Switzerland uses that
with reasonable success and I think
we'll see more and more push along that
line I think government will be the
greatest beneficiary in terms of its
efficiency the way it attracts things
uses paperwork gathers knowledge shares
that knowledge it's right you know take
tax collecting or medical payments these
things can be made an order of magnitude
more effective I I don't think any
government will be able to restrict
information flow to its citizens as much
as in the past every advance in
communication from the phone to the fax
machine have have made that far more
difficult the internet just takes that
to a new level and so governments will
have to operate in an environment where
citizens have access to all the full
range of opinions I fully agree with
what bill said let me add
thing else big question raised in
various settings here in Davos about
governments is what is their role
insofar as the information crossing
national boundaries whereas you know the
Internet doesn't isn't subjected to any
passports or checkpoint
I have some suggestions about that for
governments I think within a nation the
government should try to preserve the
cultural status quo of that nation by
using technology to that end let me
explain if you believe in your nation
that anonymity should never exist then
you can use technology of public key
cryptography require every message to be
signed which will call for a public key
to be used to read it and then you'll
know who sent that message or who was at
that site if on the other hand you want
to be open you can do that if you want
to have a rating system there is
technology so that even third parties
can rate the sites that you can access
so within a nation I think governments
should try to preserve the cultural
status quo because thousands of years
have been spent to build up this
cultural status quo nothing has changed
the people are still the same but the
difficult thing is what happens between
nations and there I think governments
should strike agreement among each other
internationally we've had the same
situation with crime we've had the same
situation with trade and I think we
should do the same they should begin
striking agreements as to what they will
do with each other if there are
violations through their boundaries and
borders well I think I can agree with
all that but there are a few very tricky
problems let's say somebody in the US
writes something that is sort of Nazi
propaganda
which is clearly allowed by the freedom
of speech in the US and is clearly
banned by German laws who should deal
with that well the US government is not
I can almost assure you
gonna force a reading to be put on that
page in Germany you have many internet
service providers who none of whom have
the resources to filter the world net
and see if there's anything appropriate
out there so in between the person who
published in the US and the person who's
receiving that would say that Germans
don't want to have happen who's going to
find that and block it and unfortunately
in country by country you're gonna have
to get resources together to see which
things are out there that you don't want
to come in you can have a policy of only
letting things in that you review but
that would probably overwhelm you and
you'd lose the benefits in the internet
or have a policy of just blocking
certain name things but you'll have to
accept the fact that that things will
get through and so whatever cultural
restriction or whatever culture has
relied on restricting information flow
is it's not going to be that won't be
there as a tool as much as it as it has
been well I agree that there will be
imperfections I don't want to take more
time debating this let me make a couple
of announcements first of all following
immediately after this session will be
the president of South Africa mr.
Mandela who has agreed to come and speak
for a short while and the audience is
asked to please stay for his address the
second announcement I'm asked to make is
speakers please identify yourselves
your name and where you're from before
asking your question let's move on to a
next question please I have a question
Margaret Wilson chairman of Scarborough
is Austin Texas I'm interested in your
perspectives on future meetings of the
World Economic Forum either here in
Davos around the world and how
technology may affect these and how they
may be different as a result realizing
that Klaus Schwab has already brought a
great deal of technology here and
provided us with computers to use for
messages and other services and secondly
would be interested bill and you're
sharing a little bit more about with us
about your home as relating to
technology and how that
they affect our homes in the future okay
well if my home is the future then
there'll be a lot of large homes that
take a long time to get built the the
key neat thing I've done done with this
home is really pushed and limit on
screen technology and by put a lot of
screens all over the place that it'll be
quite some time before those are mass
market type items there are LCD
projector technologies there are there's
a chip technology called direct digital
mirror
device that's a texas instrument
approach and these are very neat ways of
displaying images with incredible
quality and so a company there are many
companies that are gathering image
libraries and putting those on to the
Internet I'm involved with a company
called Corvis that does that and does it
at very high resolution and those images
are indexed so that you can find them
easily so if I'm one day at home saying
I'm interested in Russia I can have
images come up on all the screens of the
house about Russia and if I'm passing by
one I'm curious about its background and
we're aiming just like that I just click
on a little remote control and get that
information and see more so whether it's
Renaissance art or sailboats or sunsets
any topic those images come in and it's
very fun informative and educational
that's probably the thing that that's
been done it's the most unusual okay let
me take the other part of your question
what about the World Economic Forum the
to answer that question it's a broader
question that you're raising I think
which is really what kind of activities
pass and do not pass what kind of human
activities pass and do not pass through
the wires and the wireless links of the
networked society and that's a
fascinating question let me suggest some
pretty simple things straight text
information images video pass rather
nicely video conferencing we could be
talking to each other and passing
signals to each other emotions I believe
they pass partially we cry and laugh in
front of our TV I don't see why we won't
cry and laugh in front of this do we
extend to cry and laugh here you can
carry that through the electronic world
but there are some things I submit that
do not pass at all and maybe I can
demonstrate can I touch you here good
thank you
if bill I don't know maybe he would
react badly yes if bill had not gone to
Harvard if he had come to MIT and if you
hadn't left Harvard god knows what will
happen to the software industry but it
would illustrate my point if he was
graduating from MIT and he was my
student and a good student and all that
I could grab him here by the collar and
I could say bill I expect you to do very
well when you graduate from here now I
could email that to him right but it
wouldn't be the same I could pass it
through video and it would be a little
better but still he wouldn't feel the
pain here or I could use the things we
described in our books which are the
tactile things you talked about and the
body nets and the body suits I talked
about so either he could wear a suit and
feel the pressure while he sees me
approaching or a robot could grab him I
mean any one of these solutions could
work but let me let me put a medical
show but let me make the point that that
is not the same thing now this is a
serious point why because both bill
knows and I know that we can turn off
the switch and stop the robot so the the
whole thing is cerebral it's not a
primal force and I believe these primal
forces of the cave the forces that we
felt when millions of years ago we were
in the cave the animal growling at the
door or you know the nurturing we felt
for a loved one or the food the wish for
those things those primal forces cannot
pass now you're going to say how many of
these primal forces
we use in the World Economic Forum I
suggest that we use a lot of them in our
daily life the relationships between
siblings between doctor and patients the
trust that we build with business
associates
are all based on the force of the case
and at MIT where were thinking of having
a virtual classes we will be requiring
students to come back every year or
every two semesters to take courses on
campus so they can feel these forces of
the cave build the trust recharge their
batteries so I think an answer to your
question a lot can happen through the
network but ultimately you'll have to
come back to divorce it's a it's a very
good question because although face to
face meetings will always be superior in
many many respects to even the best
video conferencing environments
sometimes a face to face meeting is so
much trouble you'll take the the lesser
approach videoconferencing business to
business is going to catch on wildly I
mean you know when people see this
welcome system a lot of what they're
responding to is high quality
videoconferencing whose price is getting
to be very reasonable and so we need you
know it's it's a very good question how
many things like this they'll be the
speeches we're all sitting in a room
here that can be recreated through
technology very easily what can't be
recreated is when you get up and you're
sort of mingling around meeting somebody
new running into somebody at dinner and
kind of the isolation we have that we're
all here in in this common meeting which
is a very important element of it okay I
think we've answered this one enough
let's go to another question yes and
then on the other side please
first here my question is my name is IEC
Makani president of Afghan line my
question would be given that the
internet will encourage forces of
capitalism isn't there going to be a
time when we're going to need regulation
and if
we're gonna need regulation who would be
doing it otherwise the whole system will
crack at some stage well I think I
answered this by asking for regulation
first within the countries for the
activities within the country and then
pairwise regulations as we do with trade
and crime for cross-border activities
but bill but you may want to add more to
that the the question was about
restrictions on content primarily no
it's mostly international mostly from an
international point of view you're gonna
get certain companies getting really big
the extent probably where they can
control regulation and other governments
and wouldn't there come a stage when we
probably should start regulating it
early enough before it's too late
is there a need for that and if there is
who would be the right body at the
international scale regulation at this
stage well it's never too late this is
probably targeted towards Bill and
Microsoft because there are people
already complain it it's already too big
well geez Microsoft's actually pretty
small company
honestly it may be one of the smallest
companies here at this event it's
certainly not in the top thousand large
companies if you know sectors of the
economy where prices can come down by a
factor of four as they have in software
by having such rapid improvements those
are those are the ultra competitive
sectors of the economy and I wish I was
in an industry where somebody's future
was guaranteed but if you take any
industry and you say what leader of an
industry might be to placed in the next
10 years you would pick the leaders of
the technology business they are the
most at risk they are sort of surfing
the wave if they miss a technology if
they don't list them all to their
customers they don't hire smart people
they are gone whereas in many other
businesses you have brand assets
manufacturing assets distribution assets
that are great protection and that's why
the technology business people
they run scared certainly we do in terms
of thinking boy will we be the one to do
new products so I think the the toughest
parts of this relate to the network in
pricing of the network because there
it's it's more economical to only have
one person build the lot of the very
high speed elements of the network and
yet the having the right touch of
regulation where you and you encourage
innovation and yet you know what the
pricing model should be that still has
yet to be figured out I do not have this
fear of bigness corporate bigness
because the technology helps the
individual as much or more than it helps
the large company let me explain in the
industrial age you could not build a car
or any other major product in your
living room or in your study but in this
information age you can certainly sell
your information work or your
information products or services from
your home so I think what this does it
gives a capability to a lot of
individual people to sell products
services information as well as to
freely exchange it and I think it
counteracts some of the fears that you
have about about signs the other thing
it does and it was raised here in this
in this forum one or two years ahead by
Lord
Yehudi Menuhin and it was the capability
of this new technology to make the
millions of voiceless people up to now
become heard so I think we have some
positive things ahead of us to look
forward to let's have another question
mr. gates Alexei Pushkov Russian Public
Television you were pretty critical of
people who are spending hours before a
television screen but there were some
reports in the press that your company
together with NBC is investing few
billion dollars into a global television
broadcasting system is it is it the
right information first if it is how
will it affect the nature of the
television and what is the different
difference from the today's satellite
testing television no there's no meaning
in MBC together with Microsoft has done
a news service and an internet site but
certainly there's no investments of
billions of dollars or anything related
to a satellite infrastructure there it's
just one of the many news services that
you'll find on the internet and there's
some very very healthy competition there
ladies and gentlemen we have some new
high-level guests with us and we have
been asked to finish this session to
close it now so that we may hear from a
high-level guest so I would like to
thank Bill and the audience for a very
exciting and informative session thank
you
you